bonjour Fabrice Epelboin merci d'être
avec nous ou sur arte France ce weekend
Marc donc les 4 mois de l'affaire
Pegasus 4 mois après on en est où
on en est nulle part on en est à peu
près la même situation que 4 mois après
l'affaire Snowden un peu de bruit dans
la presse beaucoup moins qu'avec la
faire connaître mais pas grand
changement à l'horizon
les discussions entre dirigeants
français il a l'air secrètement eu lieu
à Paris en octobre l'État hébreu
serait engagé à ce qu'elle est numéro
français ne puisse plus être ciblé par
par Pegasus
ou d'autres logiciel espion dans les
faits ça donne quoi
dans les fesses et des discussions qui
sont infiniment facile à établir dans la
mesure où l'ancien ambassadeur de France
pour le
numéro de téléphone
[Musique]
tu as pas de demander des comptes au
Maroc pas plus que la France a demandé
des comptes à
je me souviens plus de ça
[Musique]
ça sert à rien du tout cette part
quelques articles de presse dans les
médias qui s'est encore cette affaire
notamment ceux qui ont été
victimes de cette surveillance
[Musique]
merci Fabrice Epelboin d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
enseignant à Sciences-Po spécialiste du
numérique et des réseaux sociaux